well let's get more on the situation on
the ground in ukraine from defence and
security analyst professor michael
clarke um and michael uh
we've seen overnight russia successfully
taking severe donetsk why is that so
significant and so important it's been
bubbling under for a long time hasn't it
yes i mean it's symbolically significant
it's the last
city in uh luhansk which is the northern
part of the donbass area the smaller
city across the river of lichishansk but
silver didn't yet it was only 100 000
people but nevertheless it's the it's
the city that gives russia the northern
part of the donbass they started the
offensive 10 weeks ago it's taken them
six weeks since they started to really
attack tere don yet to get to the river
which divides it from the city over the
other side of the river and the
ukrainians obviously were withdrawing
last week they were clearly pulling
forces out there was a sort of news
blackout about it sensibly enough and so
the ukrainians are giving them silver
done yet now in a way about three weeks
ago we thought they were withdrawing i
think they decided to go back over the
river and keep fighting for it in order
to make the russians pay the maximum
price to take this city that's what
they've done another place that we've
heard about is snake island just tell us
what the latest is there yeah it's an
interesting thing there's a battle
within a battle snake island um fell to
the russians on day one it was a very
big issue of course uh at the time
it was when the ukrainians told the
moskva uh the ship to what it could do
with itself um and they russians took
over snake island um
the ukrainians have
chased them off it but they've never
been able to reoccupy it themselves
they've actually
attacked russian forces on snake island
the russians put a big effort into
getting air defense units back on snake
island and potentially some maritime
missiles and the point about snake
island is it controls access to odessa
from the sea if you if the ukrainians
own snake island they could create some
maybe some safe routes for grain convoys
to come back and forth it would still be
pretty dangerous but they could if the
russians control snake island then they
have complete coverage over what may
happen in the waters around odessa so
that's that's why it's important and it
goes on it's a sort of air battle and a
missile battle and at the moment snake
island is full of russian facilities
many of which seem to have been
destroyed um and just a final thought
really on on
why do you think russia attacked kiev
last night it's there's been a pause
really on its attacks there of course
the timing just before the g7 yeah and
it's very deliberate i mean
president putin always does this
whenever there's a big diplomatic event
in the west that he thinks is going to
be anti-russian he he launches a series
of attacks or orders them to be launched
to show that he doesn't care to show
that he reserves the right to attack
what he wants but in this case these are
the residential blocks that were hit
there was a site near it the artem
industrial park which did have
ammunition facilities in it that would
be a logical uh target but it looks as
if they missed they did attack other
targets elsewhere in ukraine military
targets there were army bases army
training bases in viv and chernahiv but
this one was about as symbolically
foolish as you could imagine on the eve
of the g7 they went for a target missed
and hit a residential block that's the
message they've sent to the leaders in
munich okay michael thanks very much for
taking us through all of that